[Music]
the year is 15 seee and the Roman Empire
is prospering most of the credit will go
to the Emperor
but this success wouldn't have been
possible without loyal soldiers like
serious Felice said huius enlisted as a
legionary eight years ago at age
eighteen the son of a poor farmer with
few prospects unlike the majority of
legionaries he doesn't gamble so he's
been able to save most of his wages
he's even kept his via tucum the three
gold coins he received when he enlisted
if he survives until retirement he'll
receive several acres of land and he's
grown rather fond of a girl back home
whom he intends to marry but he'll have
to wait until he completes his 25 years
of service before that can happen and
the life of a legionary is dangerous and
grueling today Sirius is Legion along
with three others has undertaken a great
march of 30,000 Roman paces the
equivalent of nearly 36 kilometres
Seto uses armor and weapons including
his Gladius scoot 'm and to pilla way
over 20 kilograms and that's not
counting his backpack or Tsar kena
which contains food and all the tools he
needs to help build the camp spade saw
pickaxe and basket
although say Lewis is exhausted he won't
sleep much tonight he's been assigned
the first watch which means looking
after the baggage enemies and keeping
alert against a possible ambush after
he's done he lies awake dreading the day
ahead which will force him to recall his
worst nightmare
at dawn serious eats breakfast with his
7/10 companions they're like a family
all bearing scars from the battles
they've fought together
sodoes is from italia but his fellow
soldiers hail from all over the Empire
which stretches from Syria to Spain so
they're all far from home in the
northern land of Germania
Seto uses Legion and three others with
him today are under the command of
emperor Tiberius nephew
Germanicus named for his father's
military successes against the Germanic
tribes each Legion has close to 5,000
men divided into cohorts of about 500
further subdivided into centuries of
around eighty to a hundred men each
century is commanded by a Centurion and
Aquila fur or Eagle Bearer
marches at the head of each Legion
carrying its Eagle standard
the Centurions marched beside the
Legionaries belting out orders decks sin
decks sin right left right left starting
with the right foot as the left is
considered unlucky or sinister despite
the strict discipline there's tension in
the air last year some legions in the
area revolted demanding better pay and a
cut in the length of service only their
generals charisma and negotiating skills
prevented wholesale mutiny today is a
just March only 30 kilometers as the
marshes and forests of Germania lie
beyond the empires road system the men
must build causeways and bridges to make
headway something they've recently spent
more time doing than fighting finally
they arrive at their destination a place
Elias knows too well it's a clearing on
the outskirts of the Teutoburg forest
where six years ago during the reign of
the Emperor Augustus Germanic tribes
under their chieftain Arminius ambushed
and destroyed three legions proceeding
along a narrow path the legions were
attacked from forest cover under
torrential rain with their escape
blocked it was one of the worst defeats
the Romans ever suffered and Augustus
never lived it down
Cestius was one of the few survivors
said Oh eeeh still has nightmares of his
comrades lying where they fell
but now the army is back to bury the
dead with full military honors as he
helps in the task he can't help
wondering whether the bones he handles
belonged to someone he knew several
times he wants to weep aloud but he
pushes on with the task the glory of the
Empire can go to the crows all he craves
is to retire on a small farm with his
wife to be if the gods should spare his
life for 17 more years if you want to
learn more about the hopes dreams and
daily trials of life in ancient
civilizations check out our
day-in-the-life playlists you can also
support our nonprofit mission by making
a small monthly contribution on
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]